Dolly Parton is joining forces with her  goddaughter - iris I'm gonna be singing  Jolene with Molly and the pentatonix  Jolie Joe it won't be the first time we  hear Miley perform her godmothers hit  song on The Voice you please don't take  my man she gave an impromptu performance  with a contestant earlier this season  she's doing great  I think she's doing wonderful the  ratings are really up and I think a  lotta has to do with Miley being on the  show it's certainly been a who's who of  country on this season of the voice  we've seen superstar couple Faith Hill  and Tim McGraw come on as advisors and  earlier this month Garth Brooks stopped  by as a guest mentor and this week's  Dolly Miley duet we'll be sure to bring  the house down I was really a pro Molly  I've always said no matter what you  think of Molly she is so talented and  she is so natural  [Music]